(fun upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Like, I'm gonna totally
rip this whole plan
and just perform in this for
a tour-on-tour at some point.
This is so rock and roll.
- This is so beautiful rock and roll.
- It's like elegant Fleetwood Mac.
I'm just, it's very nice.
I'm just saying.
- Well I have to tell you,
I'm having an out-of-body
experience right now
because I was backstage
and I saw you backstage.
- Yeah.
- In a rust-colored dress.
And you were standing like this.
- Did you?
- With a microphone to your mouth
and you had your hand like this.
- Oh. (Kelly laughs)
- And I said, be quiet, she's praying.
(Kelly and audience chuckle)
And I said, this is
like something she does
before she goes on.
And I stood there and I kind of looked
and nodded over there.
This is what I saw people.
- This is fun.
- It was her cutout.
- So for a minute-
- I was dying.
- For a minute, I was
like, am I gonna go with it
and pretend I was
backstage in another dress?
- No.
- [Kelly] Earlier.
But yes, as soon as you
said I was praying...
This is what they put out
when they do the lighting and everything.
This is when they do the
stage of the Kellyoke.
- I began praying.
(Kelly laughs)
I was like, well this is the way to do it.
I was like, I need to be-
- She's very into it.
- Then I said to you're a stage manager
when you came on in the green.
I said, but who is that then?
Still thinking it was a live person.
- Oh my God.
- I said, who is was that over there?
I'm a ding-dong.
- It literally, no you're not.
It's me.
And the first time they
introduced it, a long time ago,
I don't even remember
season, probably season one.
I was like, I looked and
I was like, oh my God.
I was like, I thought they
were playing footage back.
- [Marcia] Yeah.
- Like upstairs.
And I was like, oh, they're playing.
What song was this?
- It's just the way it's back there.
It looks like, you have to
be backstage in the darkness.
- And how they light it.
- They light it.
- Yeah.
- It was gonna talk to me
in a minute.
- But for a minute this
was gonna be hysterical,
'cause I was just gonna lie and go with it
that I was backstage.
I was like-
- I'm not gonna make Marcia look stupid.
Right?
- I'm not gonna do it.
I was like, totally was
backstage in a dress like that.
- "Yeah, I was, Marcia.
Marcia needs a little help."
Oh my God.
- Wait, you were at the
Critics Choice Awards?
- I was.
- Okay. I think it could
be a really fun event
'cause I did hear Cate
Blanchett like, she was like,
oh why don't we just get rid
of televised award shows?
And I was like, I get what that is
because it's like we do
have a lot of award shows.
We're like, no, you're awesome.
You're awesome.
- Right.
- But I don't think it's for us really.
Like even the award, it's awesome to win,
but it's for the fans.
- Yes.
- Like I think it is, that
that was explained to me.
They're like, take you out of it.
It's for like all the people that love you
and love to support you
and love what you do.
Like it's for them.
So go for them.
- It's your gratitude too in that moment
because nobody gets anywhere on their own.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like you are you
from the minute you start,
you have people supporting you
and helping you and supporting
you and helping you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the team of a film.
And there's so many people
that make it wonderful.
So it is wonderful to have that gratitude.
What do you get nervous
about? You're like a goddess.
- Here's the thing.
- What are you nervous about?
I get, you just said it.
I get anxiety about-
I would rather be nominated
and not win because you
have to do this speech.
No, and I get, I get anxiety.
It's not like talking in
front of people is hard
but like even like recently,
the People's Choice Award.
I forgot every-
First of all, you get up
there and no one tell-
You can't see this, but
they're like, "Wrap it up".
"Wrap it up."
Like right when you walk up.
- Right. That's right.
- They're telling you to shut up.
And you're like...
- 45 seconds.
(Kelly screams)
- I haven't-
- You're so right.
- And then I panic again.
And I get anxiety and I'm
like, I didn't thank everyone.
And then I feel like they're,
they don't think that I'm grateful.
- [Marcia] Yes.
- It's a whole-
- I'm with you on that.
- And when you're nominated
you're like, congratulations.
(Kelly claps)
Good luck.
- [Marcia] Good luck.
- With your speech.
It's so hard.
- Have a little more champagne.
- And they literally, I'm not kidding you
I walked up there, turned to the camera
and it said, "Wrap it up."
- "Wrap it up."
That's exactly-
Well wait, wait, how
about getting up there?
Did you see the path to get up there?
- And then getting up
there. I'm gonna fall.
- It was like a maze.
No, it was Hunger Games to
get up to the freaking stage.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then you and then the stairs
and there's no handrail and you're like
in your beautiful dress
trying to get up there.
And then what if Colin
Farrell doesn't stand up
and help you up the stairs?
- [Kelly] Oh, but what if he does?
- What if you're like the
one he doesn't stand up for?
You're like, dude, I'm trying
to get up the stairs too.
- [Kelly] Be a gentleman.
- Right? No, but he's so gorgeous.
That's why I was like,
I wonder who was (indistinct)
before I got there.
Like it was, it was, you
see the real gentleman
they get up and they-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Put their hand out
and maybe they kiss you and it's like-
- Oh.
- It's like, who-
- I want this exp-
I've never had this
experience winning a award.
- I haven't either.
That's why I want it.
- Oh, I'm like, is this like
did they save this moment
for like Salma Hayek, like whatever.
I don't remember having that.
- No. Yes.
Salma Hayek, gets all the moments.
- No, I just meant we
all have those moments.
Even Meryl probably had these moments like
where you know, you feel like,
damn, I could have done that
better than I just did it.
Or you just have an off days.
Because it's an interesting
thing to have a job.
- [Marcia] Yes.
- Where you have to be on all the time.
And everybody has an off day.
- Every day is an off day.
A little moment in every
day is an off day, right?
- Especially for creative people.
- Yeah,
- [Kelly] We're crazy.
- But that's part of it.
- So tell us about
"Daughter of the Bride".
- "Daughter of the
Bride" is a love rom-com,
which I know you love rom-coms.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And in this, it's not the
daughter getting married.
She is the daughter of the bride.
I'm getting married.
My character is getting married.
So my character had been
single for a long time.
Totally happy single, never
wanna be married again.
And her, she and her
daughter developed this-
It's Halston Sage wonderfully
plays the daughter.
We developed sort of a
dysfunctional relationship.
Like we're the best buddies.
We do everything together.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And when I meet someone that
she sort of introduces me to
and I start moving toward
a relationship with him,
she gets really upset and
jealous and she doesn't-
- Oh, the codependency?
- The codependency.
- Yeah.
- And she doesn't want me
to be with him.
And she's against love, herself.
And of course 'cause it's a rom-com.
We all find love in the end.
And that's what it's about.
- Yeah 'cause it's not real life.
(audience and Kelly laughing)
- No, but in real life.
In real life we've both been
through it and you know?
- Would you ever get married again?
- Hell no.
- I won't either.
No. Here's the thing
and I'm not against it.
I think you should if you want to.
- Being in love is fantastic.
- I just, yeah. Being in
love, I'm not against it.
I think people think you have to do both.
I'm like, I think you can love someone
and not have to like have them
around you all the time and-
- Snore.
- And especially if you have
kids like you know stepparent
that could be a little, it's
just an interesting dynamic.
- Listen here's the real, I'm
falling in love with myself.
After I got divorced I
fell in love with myself.
- Yeah.
- And that is it.
- We forget, you put
yourself in the back burner.
- You forget, on the back burner.
I have the best girlfriends.
- Yeah.
- So I like, I'm living a good life
and you know I did this thing
called uncoupled in New York
and it's, that's why was it
the Broadcast Film Critics,
and I realize the only
answer to uncoupling
when you uncouple is not
necessarily recoupling.
Sometimes it is about-
- I think that's the
biggest mistake sometimes.
Especially right after.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because you think I
needed to define myself
through someone else and you don't,
you define yourself through you.
- Yeah. I'm enjoying it.
- At first it's hard you.
- You are.
- 'Cause you're like used to something
and you wanted to make
something work, but honestly-
- And you're heart broken.
- You're heart broken.
- That so sad.
- But once you get past
that you're just like,
I kind like this whole bed.
- I was like-
(Marcia laughs)
- This king bed just became a queen.
- I love that. I'm gonna
steal this from you.
- It's awesome.
- Fly birdie.
- I have to share with my dogs now
'cause they're like, "Oh he's gone?".
"Okay."
So it's like that's not
what was supposed to happen.
But you're also on this
series, "So Help Me Todd."
which is the greatest (indistinct).
So how's that it title?
How's that going?
- It's so fun. It's so fun.
Skylar Astin is amazing and
it's a mother-son dysfunctional-
- I love how they don't connect-
- Fantastic relationship.
Right. She's very like
by-the-book's lawyer
and he's very like
outside-the-world investigator.
And then it's how we work together.
And there's a lot of,
it's a lot of banter.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- There's a lot of laughs.
- There's a case of the week.
It's really fun.
- [Kelly] I love that.